i don't wanna wait squiddy squash
squiddy [ __ ] butter squid is squatted
squiddy squiddy squee
sorry that was the anthem of the
of the of the whites
when i was growing up
anyways what's going on my genius brain
people real quick before the podcast
starts you little genius farts guess
what live show announcement i told you
it was coming november 11th at the house
of blues today today the tickets are
live only for people who use the code
genius that's right tomorrow though on
the friday
that's when it goes live for everybody
else but make sure you guys cop a ticket
and i will see you there because i am
performing or doing a live podcast show
and taping maybe
with bose bozington herself the true
host of genius bows my friends that's
right me and bows will be at the house
of blues my friends in anaheim on
november's 11th homie y'all gonna be
there homie or what what's up
house of blues anaheim november 11th we
will see you there and i'm going to be
continually reminding you in the
beginning of these podcasts up until
november 11th because you know your boy
wants to see your face and we got to
have that place packed out are my genius
farts gonna be there i think so we gonna
have merch we gonna have hugs and we
gonna have masks too hopefully well by
then who knows but we shall see
see you then let the podcast roll baby
wait
didn't the other day mario forget about
your lunch too
oh
my
gosh
i completely forgot she was causing this
whole [ __ ] scene and i set up a lunch
date with her not too long ago and she
also forgot guess what hold on a second
you let me finish my sentence this is
what happened she forgot her our lunch
date too right
but she's over here all
in five four three two one hello
everybody welcome to
genius brain podcast welcome to the
genius brain podcast welcome to try it
again in five four three two
one welcome to the genius frame fart
podcast
oh she thinks she's so funny
not doing in japanese
[Music]
welcome to
genius brain podcast
now do it in mandarin
uh
welcome oh my god you have lost all your
language dude uh
uh i'm kind of upset right now because
there was two podcasts that i was doing
and somehow by chance
this [ __ ] mic cord slipped out and so
i get the [ __ ]
i have to redo these podcasts and this
was supposed to be a podcast that she
and i was supposed to do later this week
but now we're doing it right now and i'm
not in a good mood and i have my p jones
because i was gonna go to bed
but you know for the sake of my fiance
because i'm such a good person
here i am recording i have been in the
shittiest mood this week it has been it
has been hard to manage these emotions
you've been very emotional indeed a lot
of things have been happening that has
been pissing me off a lot of waves been
able to control these emotions and i
just want to just just kill somebody i
thought you're
doing better after hawaii did hawaiiana
wasn't as great as it was supposed to be
because of look it was fun you were
there we went to these beaches
but the island was so packed
like hawaii is so impacted right now and
if you guys don't know if you guys are
going to hawaii this year here's the
thing if you go there and you're
expecting
we're talking about either maui or it
doesn't matter what island you go to
maybe except for big island
tourism is
flowing through hawaii
every jackass in the [ __ ] united
states specifically jackasses are going
to hawaii and just ruining it for
everybody else
i have nothing to compare with so i was
like this is great
but i guess you have
it was just so packed there was traffic
everywhere there was there was there was
just [ __ ] on the road just these
people were so irritating
so basically you didn't get the rest
that you wanted it was just a lot more
hectic like
hawaii was so packed we couldn't get
dinner reservations anywhere let alone
lunch reservations
which is nuts
at any place even even some of the
restaurants that i go to when i don't
have any other choice and they're open
later
even they didn't have reservations i was
like how is this possible
i i
i don't know it just seemed like vegas
to me and then when we go to the
supposed to feel like that
well i didn't have much
so it was just all great and i'm sorry
yours wasn't
i i was i've been in such a bad mood
lately just angry as hell
and she has been dealing with my wrath
so much
mm-hmm i'm glad you noticed
i do i i think i was dealing with it
quite well although i'm like this guy's
insane
i just let you be
but but
you you are doing a bit better
so what are you gonna do
i don't know i haven't been this upset
in a very long time like these type of
like being emotionally volatile is
something that i really don't like i
don't like my emotions going from zero
to a hundred constantly just going up
and down up and down up and down it is
irritating it's exhausting it causes me
stress i can't sleep well how do you how
do you fix that how do you overcome it
usually i just punch somebody in the
[ __ ] face you've done that already no
i do
not punch them in the face you s slap
but still like at this point in my life
man like i'm so exhausted
here's the thing too like if you guys
don't know when i was younger i used to
have crazy anger management issues right
and
so growing up it's like this like you
grew up in a korean household right
korean people have this habit of always
being angry that's what we're known
we're known as the the spicy japanese
this is who we are we got fire in our
heart yeah we have han and the other
side is
i mean they're similar yeah like han is
i don't know what it is but it's like
revenge rage i don't know what the exact
but you're just hot yeah right and a lot
of korean people have this han
is it i thought han is more like
more on the sad side like is it and the
og is more like
oh gretch
is like hi guys
yeah but i don't know but we have like
these wide ranges of emotions right
growing up in my household especially at
the korean house so i saw a lot of anger
it's honestly how a majority of our
problems were solved like the way i used
to see my parents fight was typical that
apparently a lot of other korean kids
saw growing up like it was just
extremely volatile like i remember just
as a kid just watching my parents scream
at each other 24 7. and this is not me
bashing on what
they did as adults and how they dealt
with their relationship it's just at the
time it was look i grew up [ __ ] poor
right we were broke as [ __ ] and the way
that we would deal with our emotions and
the way that we would deal with things
was was based on the level of stress
that we lived in and how quickly we
could resolve these problems right so
some people asked this where
when we had this conversation about oh
would you would you like whoop your kids
i don't know maybe i'll spank them here
and there but definitely not the level
that my parents did
and i think a lot of the times when
people question
um what immigrant parents do they go
well i can't believe they would hit
their child i can't believe they would
do this and that like you also have to
realize the
circumstances that somebody's in yeah
also their generation like when i was
living in korea in korean school people
students get spanked by their teachers
with a huge ass like ruler stick
so that was the culture we lived in it
wasn't like
it wasn't violent i mean
there i think the definition of domestic
violence here or any kind of child abuse
is extreme here but in korea we're in a
lot of asian countries too like they
it wasn't
to the extreme that americans are
thinking but it was part of our culture
where like if you don't do it right you
get spanked dude like in korean churches
you know how you would get like
hand-me-down clothes you can get
hand-me-down ass weapons
in churches like if you if you messed up
somebody else's parents would [ __ ]
whoop your ass and it was completely
okay yeah yeah and like how my parents
used to deal with a lot of their
frustrations was just like getting
advice screaming yelling a lot and this
is what i was taught even when i was a
kid and i mentioned this story on the
podcast before like i remember okay so
we used to live out in these duplexes in
sacramento called uh tem woods i'm not
sure if it's super bad now but back in
the day tim woods
was not a very nice place and we before
we lived in those duplexes we used to
live in these apartments off of mack
road
and uh tim woods at the time depending
on what parts that you would go to that
was just a block of just like samoan
bloods right so there was a lot of like
there was just a block that was just all
samoan bloods and it was it was like
gang affiliated streets there were some
places that were trap houses and trap
houses are basically prostitution places
like this is the neighborhood that i
grew up in uh right uh it might be
cleaned up now i'm pretty sure it's not
like that anymore because a lot of that
stuff has been cleaned up but when i was
a kid that's what that neighborhood was
like
and i remember when i was younger
um there was a a bunch of kids in the
neighborhood we used to play a lot right
and
um
at the swap meet there used to be this
stick with with glitter with glitter in
it and we used to play with it do you
remember this it was like liquid inside
yeah
so i had the stick uh and we were
playing with the neighborhood kids i let
this kid see the stick he grabbed it and
he was like this is mine
and i'm like no that's
you know
long story short
he ended up taking that [ __ ] from me i
started crying i went back home and my
dad was like
where's the thing i just got you because
he got it for me at the swap meet he
goes this kid took it he goes cool
you're not coming back into this house
until you get it back what
yeah well how old were you i was if if
we were at that area i moved to the
house that we rented when i was eight so
i had to be six or seven
and i'm like okay and my dad's like
you're not gonna get dinner and you're
not coming back in the house till you
get the toy that i bought you why did he
do that
i don't know maybe he says he didn't
want me to get bullied he i have to i
have to be responsible for taking care
of my own things because he bought that
for me and i lost it in his eyes yeah
and you know as a kid you just feel like
everything's unfair like yes i just got
bullied my dad is not on my side but i
had to go back and get these toys back
so i went back i got into this
big old fight
specifically i brought like a weapon i
forgot my memory's hazy right now but i
think it was a bat but either way i beat
the [ __ ] out of that kid and i got and i
got my stick back uh-huh came back home
bloody and no not bloody it wasn't like
that we're kids you can't even swing
that hard but essentially i got my [ __ ]
back
and then my dad was like okay you can
come back in but that's how he would
deal with a lot of stuff was every every
answer for something was violence and he
knew that i used to get bullied a lot
when i was a kid
i used to get bullied all the [ __ ]
time i was that fat asian kid with
glasses and now i'm a fat asian kid as
an adult but i was a fat asian kid with
little glasses and i was generally a
sweet kid but kids would try to bully me
take my [ __ ] all the time and i think my
dad got kind of tired of it too so he's
like you got to stand up for yourself
yeah i can't speak english i can't even
communicate with their parents i can't
be there with you at the school i can't
even talk to the to the teachers so you
have to stand up for yourself yeah but
then i think the problem with that is
that when you have that rhetoric with
your kid
and you don't talk to him about the
emotional things that are happening to
you yeah everything that you do from
then on is violence
if somebody touches me i can beat them
up and that's what my dad used to tell
me he goes you don't do anything in
school stop getting in trouble but if
they touch you you can do whatever you
want yeah so i i i got in trouble so
much in school because these kids would
try to bully me and all i would say is
just touch me see what happens uh i mean
parents back then don't really talk
about emotion they don't know how to
talk i don't think we're allowed to have
emotions yeah it's like especially
korean boys like dudes they are like you
know as a guy you don't have emotions
you don't like don't don't be a [ __ ]
blah blah blah you know so you probably
he grew up in that kind of culture too
but my dad's not even like a super tough
guy though or maybe that's how i see him
as right because he was he was a pastor
too he had a lot of empathy especially
towards the community that he was
working with but then you know and but
then we grew up in a very bad
neighborhood because even after i got my
my stuff back where i had dinner the
next day those kids came to our house
and they try to beat me up and i
remember i ran into the garage and i
closed the garage and you could hear
these kids just banging on the garage
damn you know and this is and i'm super
young but my parents had to go to work
and this is just like the few days i
didn't go to work with them and they had
to leave us alone at the house and
obviously that's illegal but we didn't
have babysitters my grandma at the time
was either helping my other aunt who had
a swap meet
uh
um out in this place called denials
and i
what were we supposed to do so we were
at home just to kind of fend for
ourselves yeah this is the kind of
environment that we have and so i grew
up with this idea of like violence and
being angry as an answer because it was
a way for people to just [ __ ] leave
me alone and so now i get to these
points even as an adult my anger is a
lot better because i had to go through
anger management because i didn't know
how to deal with these emotions
it's like i see this spike where it
happens and all i all i want to do is
just punch somebody hit somebody just
[ __ ] break somebody's bones because
it's the only way what if you break your
own bone would you have it that's just
the product of what happens but you saw
this hand though right
like this hand's all messed up look at
this hand and look at this one
so i remember in junior high
um
at this point i got in so many like
stupid fist fights as a kid i got
removed from my elementary school and i
went over to junior high
um
i just had to stop getting in fights
because i would get in fights at school
my mom would be upset at me my dad would
be upset at me they would beat my ass at
home and i would get into fights to
school i'd get bullied at school it was
just
it was just [ __ ] terrible for me it's
like i have nobody supporting me at
school i have nobody supporting me at
home angry all the [ __ ] time so what
i decided to do instead of you know uh
just confronting somebody getting
physical with them i just let them mouth
off say whatever i would hold my anger
in go somewhere else and i would just
start [ __ ] punching walls punching
lockers whatever and not just to get the
aggression out but of course lo and
behold you kind of mess up this hand and
it started since i was in seventh grade
and then later on in high school
i started cursing because as a little
kid the weird thing was i never curse
because when when we were in kids as a
church if you cursed they would beat the
[ __ ] out of you i still remember when i
first said the f word when i said the
word [ __ ]
it felt i thought that satan grabbed my
heels and it was dragging me to hell
that's what it felt like
oh
i never got i mean i don't think we had
the culture of spanking or hitting
people at church but obviously was not
allowed to say it and i i mean it's not
until recent i started cursing so
you curse in the funniest way though her
cursing is so old
she'll store and bottle up her emotions
and then she'll just be out in the
middle of the kitchen out of nowhere
she'll stop as if like somebody is like
beaming in a message into her brain and
i'm like what is she doing she looks at
the floor looks up and she just goes
i'm like what the [ __ ] is going on
this is the
oddest thing i've ever done i live with
my sitcom wife she does so many sitcom
things it's hilarious i just boil it up
and i want to scream so i just yell
[ __ ]
or like what the [ __ ] yeah
but that's sad um so how did you
how are you overcoming it now i don't
even know if well i don't know i haven't
been this irritable in years like i
don't even know what is a way for you to
cope at the outside trying to punch
someone since that's not an option this
podcast is brought to you by cbd
farmhouse my friends yes
the only thing that helps me to chill
out and specifically i want to talk
about a product that i use from them
constantly and that is the sleepy time
gummies now you guys know i travel a lot
and on top of that for years i dealt
with insomnia and the only thing that
helps me get a really good night's sleep
on the nights that is super hard to
sleep or the sleepy time gummies it is a
life
saver sleeping all the way through i'm
waking up super energized for any of you
out there that just wants to chill out
and if you have trouble sleeping try it
out see what happens it's worked for me
i freaking love it i wouldn't endorse a
product that i don't use on the regular
and on top of that too if you just want
to mellow out and feel good if your
anxiety is super high oh my anxiety
people yeah get on these delta aids it's
my [ __ ]
is all use it all the time whenever my
anxiety flares up and i gotta tell you i
i don't remember what i did before this
stuff i don't use it all the time but
when i do need it it's amazing and when
i'm hurting i use the cbd freeze the
roll-ons a lot of their topical products
so make sure you guys go to
cbdfarmhouse.com
use code brain to get 15
off on all applicable items 15 off yes
they're hooking it up you won't regret
it i love it it's become a daily part of
my life whenever i need it and whenever
i need it it's right there for me so
make sure you guys go to
cbdfarmhouse.com and use code brain to
get 15 off on all applicable orders i
don't know like it's very weird right
now i i don't know how to deal with this
like uh there's all these so when you're
when you go through anger management
they have all these like you know steps
well it's been so many years i don't
even [ __ ] remember what they are
right but
i know like taking a breather taking a
step back and i can't even remember all
the steps anymore i think it just became
a habit of what i did you go back into
anger management i don't know i think
going to anger management now is just
going to piss me off even more
you're like i'm here again like the best
thing that i could do right now is just
stay away from people because people are
starting to exacerbate me and just make
me angry
but you're gonna go see a bunch of
people in the next few weeks your
schedule's pretty packed yeah so i'm
just gonna have to deal with it
um the weird thing is it's like being
angry like people i want you just go
work out the hard thing about me when
i'm upset and something is on my mind i
can't focus
i know what you're talking about yeah i
can't focus on work i can't even work
out because i'm i'm so distracted it's
taking all my time
can't you do something that helps you
with that destruction like for example
when i'm like going in circle vicious
cycle in my head where i can't focus on
anything i
either i usually go out with friends and
just talk it out or like do an activity
with friends that helps me like just
focus on other things or like even ryan
lee sometimes is a great like
distraction
that works sometimes it's not working
this time so i don't know why but it's
just been like being super
uh
snippy lately and i don't like it like i
don't i i it's not like i don't
recognize it it's not like i can't
so the best thing for me is just to like
okay i just need to be alone and be away
from people
it's just now it's just
it's just anything is starting to set me
off you know that feeling it's what we
have every month it's called pmsing okay
no joke but we have absolutely no reason
to be
agitated it's just our hormones wants to
kill us
when we first started going out
she um
she she was never
i'm her first serious relationship so
basically i never had a man agitate
my emotion to to the extent he does only
because she hasn't been around somebody
that long so like when you have
acquaintances right and you have people
around you that
um aren't that close you have an option
to just ignore them or just walk away
yeah but when you're in a serious
relationship this person is there they
are on your mind they're on your heart
yeah in front of my face all the time
you can't just go away be like i'm not
gonna see that person for a month so and
also too like when you're not when you
haven't been in like multiple serious
relationships there's certain humps that
you go over and learn in the process in
terms of like messing up
that she didn't get to experience it
yeah so one of the frustrating things
that i felt that i had to deal with when
we first started going out was i had to
relearn or redo everything from when i
first started dating all over again
pmsing it's like
because it got so once somebody has
multiple relationships and they have
like the whole the pms thing they start
to realize oh i'm pmsing right now this
is why i'm being irritable so this
person just needs to get the [ __ ] away
from me right yeah in her case she i
remember this too like i asked her i was
like hey
is it your time of the month right now
right and you're like oh because i'm a
woman you know you went on this whole
feminist thing and i was like no no
that's not what it is i said when when
you are on your time of the month it's
understandable because you're irritable
so if you're irritable i'll just i'm
just gonna go away but i never been that
agitated from by someone so i
the first thing he says is oh you're
making an excuse like
that it's my period not your attitude
and then it turns out oh crap this is
happening every month maybe it is my pms
but i didn't know because i never had
that issue before
never it was so hard to deal with
because the funny thing is if there is
no recognition of what's going on
specifically like hormonally with your
body and you can't accept the fact that
hey
the reason why my mood is like this is
not because of this person is simply
because of me
it's there's no conversation to be had
so it got to the point where i'm like
okay well i'm just going to give you
space and then she'll be like so you
don't want to be near me anymore
you don't want to be near me i just
wanted to kill him i was like okay so i
can't run away i can't be close to you
what can i do and it just got to this
point where it's finally i don't know
what happened i think we had a huge
fight and then she was like maybe it's
my time of the month
right
yeah and it's a legitimate card that she
can use because it allows me to assess
where her emotions are at that means
that the things that she's going to say
do
in this few days aren't going to make
sense to who she really is because she's
just hormonal as hell you know what's
funny though it may not be monthly but
maybe quarterly you have the same thing
and i'm just like what the hell are you
talking about you have these random not
this one but it's like similar to this
one once in a while you'll be like
everything's agitating you nothing is
working out so you're gonna have to
reorganize everything redo everything
and it's just like
but what happened well i can pinpoint
what it is it's just like a succession
of things that are [ __ ] up or people
that are pissing me off and then i'm i'm
oh yes i mean you have actually you're
not like it's not like you wake up and
out of nowhere you're just like agitated
it's just like yeah it does pile up but
then it kind of turns into him like wow
he seems like a woman because he's like
reorganizing the kitchen or like oh i do
that when i stress i start to reorganize
yeah clean things which i'm like this is
kind of nice but i wish it was like more
of a friendlier energy
but i'm like at the same time i feel
like i'm with a woman
just get the [ __ ] away from me yeah i do
know
i like before i think i'm like let's
talk or like you know i try to engage
with him so that we could like get this
you know this gross feeling away
but now
for example when this happened i think
it was yesterday or the day before
yesterday
um david was recording something in the
living room and i guess he was i wasn't
there and i guess he was agitated by
something one led to another and like
basically the whole living room just
blew up and then when i walked in
i was like what the hell happened and he
was so agitated so so agitated that i
told myself you know what i'm gonna take
the day off and hang out with my friend
and come back at nighttime because the
best thing to do is not to agitate this
fire uh it's not like the walls were
closing in on me
it felt like the room was getting
smaller and here this room everything
like the whole house was getting smaller
and smaller and smaller i'm like
everything is pissing me off i want to
get rid of everything in this house
coffee table couch
plates
pots pans whatever it all has to go
right now
yeah so he literally took everything out
of the drawers and i was like what are
you doing he's like i'm gonna clean
everything and took everything out and
laid it on the sofa and i was like
okay
i have no place to sit so i'm just gonna
bounce
it was just a really dark and trying to
ask you something
i'm going to ask you first and then you
can ask me okay
if there's one thing you could change
about me what is it
one thing to change about to be honest i
won't take it personally
no trust me
i will be honestly one thing it's just
which one
i'm just kidding uh one thing
think
wisely i'm a genie i can make it happen
what is the one thing not in real life
actually you know what what do you think
mine would be i think that would be
easier i don't know
i'm damn near perfect
like what is the one thing that i always
complain about you
socks
really that's a little priority
exactly so you decide what's the one
thing you would change about me that's
just only a reason say it right now i
don't know that's a hard question i
never thought of it
so
how do i pick one um
it will be something along the line of
planning
scheduling i guess that's the one thing
explain
as in
so david is a very busy man as we all
know
and he tries to have work-life balance
and you know sometimes go out with me or
uh schedule
an event or time with me
a lot of the times sometimes
here and there he would double book and
that's because
and i have um
proof from his co-workers too is that he
doesn't like to put things on his
calendar so it's all in his head which
is quite messy
he has an adhd type of
um organization in his head so he would
forget things for example he would
forget that he has a call in the morning
um and so
his co-workers would call me
and say hey is he up
and while i'm working and i see his
friend's name around
i don't know 10 o'clock in the morning i
would just give my phone to him as like
it's your meeting
that's the type that would happen a lot
and sometimes he would you know we would
want to plan things and i would be the
one getting canceled first because
obviously work comes first
well like once in a while it's fine but
when it becomes too often i get pretty
upset i'm like you know what in order to
prevent this which is quite easy you
just put it on your calendar this guy is
very lazy to do that he's like that's
the last thing i want to do i don't want
to have that in my task that's why he
needs an assistant but he doesn't want
an assistant so it's just it's just a
vision it's not that i don't want an
assistant it's just like having an
assistant all over again is so hard
because i had a very good assistant
vanessa therefore you don't want an
assistant no it's not that i don't want
an assistant that's not how it transfers
over i do want an assistant but that
person has to be very trustworthy that
person has to deal with everything like
bank slips all this other stuff they
literally have to deal with all this
[ __ ] and they would be and you would
have to see them all the time too the
fact is that he doesn't have anyone so
he's doing everything on his own
so and it's all in his head which even
someone like me who's very organized
feel trapped cannot do everything in my
head i need to write things down i need
to put on my calendar so that i could
have the capacity in my brain to do
other things so that my calendar reminds
me that hey i have a date with david
but uh he tends to forget so that's you
forgot about a date too though let's not
listen
that's troubleshooting was not a date
yeah
yes
okay let's let's talk about it then did
we talk about this
okay so check it out oh my god i made it
on time by the way
you did you did
you did not hold on
so
let me just tell you this let me tell
you this [ __ ] all right so mario yeah
all right
all right so oh yeah oh yeah
so
she was doing so mario does twitch where
she does her daily work stuff right i'm
exposed i do twitch guys yeah so she's
she's doing twitch
and um
i'm i forgot what i was doing exactly
i was doing something but then i get a
message oh i was i was in a boxing
lesson
and then i actually left my phone
at the house
so i couldn't be reached i'll tell the
story
let me tell you the story okay so i was
doing twitch and
the day before i okay so basically
we made a plan to have lunch date and i
was gonna treat him out because he did
something really special for me and i
can't remember what it was but i was
like you know what i'm gonna treat you
oh you know what it's because he worked
really hard in the backyard so i was
like hey let me treat you out to this
really cool
dope sushi spot
and it's a place where you have to
pre-reserve pre-pay everything
um and it's reservations only and
there's only like i think 10 seats
whatever
i told him in advance i put it on his
calendar and i remind him multiple times
when the day was coming closer because i
know he gets agitated if i remind him
too often the day of i'm like of course
he's gonna remember i was busy in the
morning doing twitch and doing other
stuff um i hear him walking around
and then i also hear him leaving
somewhere so i was like oh maybe he's
just grabbing something finished with my
stuff and i'm getting ready for the
lunch date and i go to the bathroom and
i see his cell phone and i was like oh
i guess he went to go grab something
quickly because he never forgets his
phone to leave and stuff so i couldn't
call him
well 30 minutes before our reservation
time i'm like
what's going on so i messaged his friend
nick because i'm like maybe he's at the
gym by accident forgetting about our
lunch day so i message nick and he's
like hey i'm not at the gym but let me
ask my friend who's at the gym right now
and he comes back confirming that david
is there
so i'm like um he might have forgot a
plan that we made can you let the friend
know that he has
a plan with mariel
well that friend is actually the coach
so he was too busy coaching david who
didn't have his phone and i'm like well
it's 20 minutes before a reservation it
takes me 25 minutes to get there so
i'm gonna go
without david
okay let me just say this all right all
this is very accurate so i'm feeling
guilty as [ __ ] by the way where are you
though hold on a second you you shut
your you shut your filthy mouth
you shut your filthy mouth i have been
i've never missed a date ever we've been
together seven years now
i've never missed a date
at all
so shocking i felt really really bad she
reserved this it was actually in the
calendar and i would have known if my
and the one day i forget my phone yeah
is that day how could you forget your
phone that's crazy by the way [ __ ] uh
uh rick ricky uh you didn't
you know what ricky said all he said was
like oh your girl's trying to reach you
[Laughter]
ricky
thanks the [ __ ] lot not a you have a
date with her today and so when i say oh
i was like okay cool i could just finish
this up and get back to her uh-huh so i
didn't know that part well maybe nick
didn't can maybe okay we're gonna talk
okay okay first of all nick did his best
he's like in the middle of it going back
and forth with me
kudos to nick thank you for confirming
that david was at the gym
nick is a [ __ ] [ __ ]
right you should have relayed the fact
to ricky that i had a date i didn't
remember because it's supposed to be on
the calendar and it would ding i had it
on the calendar to ding
right well it ding in the bathroom
that's for sure and i did i 30 minutes
before and
lo and behold and then you oh and then
i'm at that lunch reservation having my
sushi enjoying my time and then he gives
me a call and i'm like hello and he says
hey what's up you call
and i said uh-huh
and he has no idea
why i called him and that's the worst
two when you want that person to call
you to be like hey i'm so sorry i forgot
and my response was what's up
oh oh and it gets even better he says
what you're uh we had a lunch date
is it on the calendar
oh my gosh you see i was just like
but you knew i left my phone though
well okay if i yes i did but if you knew
as well would you ask is it on the
calendar i did well you're using that
phone but it wasn't dinging right when i
got to my phone yeah because it's after
exactly so immediately what did i do i
grabbed a hold on a second let me push
my sentence young lady what the first
thing i did was i drove so fast through
traffic i hit children i hit deer i hit
old people i killed them all i went
i crashed my car into 17 trees and 14
houses i showed up and i dove through
the window smashed the window
all right ninja i grabbed the phone and
i was like i gotta call my lady
and that's why i didn't see the calendar
so check this out i knew that she was
very very upset especially after i asked
her is it on the calendar i went and i
went to this flower shop
in pasadena that i always go to
when i [ __ ] up
and i got her a very very expensive
flower set
and when i came back she was twitching
away
doing the twitch thing and i came in and
i
gave her this flower saying i'm really
sorry and i will make it up to you
bam can i say boyfriend of the year says
sorry he apologizes no when he's wrong
and comes back with flowers boom in your
face so as this is happening we're
explaining this to the twitch people
right
and then
the most beautiful lovely lady savannah
comes in
and saved the day because savannah was
also in the twitch stream and she goes
wait
didn't the other day mario forget about
your lunch too
oh
my god
i completely forgot she was causing this
whole [ __ ] scene and i set up a lunch
date with her not too long ago and she
also forgot guess what hold on a second
you let me finish my sentence this is
what happened she forgot her our lunch
date too right
but she's over here all high and mighty
just all about her [ __ ] pet is still
looking down and poor old me you forgot
our lunch date too she went all the way
to work and then she was eating lunch i
was an idiot you were
you said you were eating lunch you're
like i was about to have lunch oh
that's right i forgot i'm eating lunch
but i'll go to you right now that is a
lie guess what i did i said when she
came to the door i said sweetie
i have never seen somebody so beautiful
in my life
[Music]
slap their face i got a chariot and i
took us to lunch and then i paid for it
so what do you have to say you have no
right you have no right this podcast is
brought to you by hello fresh listen to
all my people out there that's looking
to make bomb ass food with multiple
recipes for you to choose from you got
to go with hellofresh you know me your
boy likes to eat and i'm not gonna lie
your boy was shocked at how good the
recipe was that i followed and it turned
out to be amazing the sun-dried tomato
and creamy chicken pasta
bueno i think that's italian but what
that means in italian is freaking fire
when i'm trying to cook a meal i want it
drama-free so when i get these recipes
ingredients and delivery to my doorstep
how blessed am i but the biggest thing i
say 30 on cost with pre-portioned
ingredients that ensures that i don't
spend an extra dime on groceries that
always ends up in the trash what that is
you mister and misses 30 pounds of
celery and 12 bundles of bay leaves you
know you ain't gonna use it for nothing
after you made your once in a year gumbo
i'm talking about me so go to
hellofresh.com brain14 and use
codebrain14 for up to 14 free meals
including free shipping once again go to
hellofresh.com
brain14 and use codebrain14 for up to 14
free meals including free shipping yes
that deal is freaking nuts and i'm not
lying that's what you get my brain farts
so make sure that you go ahead and feed
your soul with america's number one meal
kid hello fresh baby
you have no right
okay you forgot our lunch too i okay
where's my flowers where's my card this
is and i'm so sorry i'm just spending a
lot of money i paid for my for someone
else
i paid for my portion yeah you just go
here here's the money oh okay that's it
no no that's not what it is no no no no
no no no no no don't don't frame it like
that
that's what you're saying you're like
i'll pay for my portion that's not the
point i'm gonna kick you in your stomach
i didn't i didn't frame it like oh it's
my money i have a lot of money you know
what i did was you know worry about it
i'll give you money oh now i'm some
chinese billionaire what am i jackman
stuff don't worry here take the take 100
i didn't do that either way
how come
you didn't apologize and give me some
flowers
because i actually made it on time you
did not make it on time i was starving
what are you talking about you just woke
up dude i did not just wake up i was you
know morning it was like it was like 12
something and i'm waiting around on the
couch crying and i'm like
and unlike you i had my phone so you
could have messaged me
don't talk over me i said with my lady
i'm so hungry
and then my stomach was going
i was making all these noises that's
because you had to go to the bathroom
and forget your phone and i was like
where where's my lady and then i call
her up and lo and behold she goes i
forgot about you you're not important to
me oh now you know this chicken salad at
my workplace is worth more than you
and i still didn't shove it in her face
so who's the better person in the
relationship me or you what's going on
are we comparing saying one's better
than the other yes who's better right
now in that situation i didn't know is
this why you brought up this question i
i didn't hold it over you no we didn't
even go into what i would change about
you
ask me
go ahead ask me what would you if
there's one thing that you want to
change about me what would your goddamn
attitude
[Laughter]
your fill your filthy stinking attitude
that's what i would change i think the
whole audience know that i don't have
the attitude no the the one thing that i
probably would change uh from mariel is
her
indecisiveness when it comes to ordering
food and drinks dude isn't that a
benefit for you because you get to order
whatever you like
i'm giving you the the the option for it
it's just not what happens this is the
thing oh you mean the other
this is the thing that marielle does
right i'm very indecisive when it comes
to menu when you guys go to a drink
place right what is the thing that you
hate the most the line is super long
there's this little asian girl right at
the front of coffee bean and tea leaf
and then she does this this little girl
walks up to them she goes hi
my name is
what do i really do
my name is
[Music]
i don't know what to get
there's so many choices 10 minutes have
passed 30 people behind her hmm okay
okay maybe
and then she goes
and then and then she'll ask
so what do you recommend and they go
okay i recommend the number four five
six and seven and she goes
i don't like that
people are behind getting pissed and i'm
the guy next to her i'm like
baby hurry the [ __ ] up there's people
behind you like don't rush me
i need time
that's what she said she's sitting like
that taking [ __ ]
forever for a drink that doesn't even
matter she goes well what if i get it
and i don't like it i was like then
we'll go back and get you another drink
it's not that big of a deal
see most people when they order drinks
and they don't know what they're going
to get they don't go in line
they take the menu and they take the
step aside you think for some reason i'm
gonna go in line and then take 30
minutes
i have to be there as i hear people
behind you like oh my god this lady dude
and i'm just like people please please
please i love her
don't be lord
i love her i love her with all of my
heart please don't slay her oh my god
allow her to keep her life i apologize
oh my god this is what i have to deal
with every time we order drinks the
indecisiveness
we are at a diner in hawaii
we are about to order food
everybody is starving
detention was so hot and did he have
what i wanted to order what is it that
you wanted to order i wanted to order
dutch
baby i wanted to order dutch baby that's
baby and they said i'm sorry honey we
are actually out of them like well
that's all i loved and their whole world
exploded and everybody was waiting for
her to finish because we were super i
wish that when you could order food you
would think ahead look at the menu have
option a option b and knock it out
other people are starving you need to be
a little considerate
be a little concerned with my time and
schedule please i am
i use my calories it's true i am very
undecisive that's why i love the fact
that i'll be like um
and then you just be like all right i'll
get this and this and this yeah but okay
i love that i do that and then what
happens is i'll order her food that i
think is really good and then she goes
it's greasy
her stuff i could tell and then her
stomach will hurt yeah and then she's
over here just complaining like oh my
god myself i'm not come i mean yes i'm
telling you how i feel about it that
just like how you do it your life this
place sucks no no i'm not i'm not upset
that you that you thought the food is
greasy i'm upset the fact that you're
eating this food you know that it's
greasy and then you choose to take 30
more bites
and you're stuck i don't like to waste
food what kind of stuff you have to
waste food you could take it to go
yes but in hawaii i don't think we
usually take it to go we did we actually
took a lot of food to go just one zippys
yeah and oh and the other stuff we
shared with other people because they
were just going to eat everything
anyways
exactly yeah that's what i would change
about you
my indecisiveness indecisiveness when it
comes to ordering food that's why i have
you deal with it
i don't do it
you've been really fit though lately
uh-huh yeah you look really good oh
thank you when you were in hawaii i was
like oh look at her you got the little
baby abs coming out and stuff yes yeah
you've been the little chopstick line
yeah you've been doing really good thank
you i think it's because i'm not going
out
just going out to eat and stuff yeah and
just eat whatever is in the house you
know
i feel like in one way pandemic bless my
body of not blowing up uh but another
way i am so anti-social like when i see
friends i'm like do i hug do i elbow do
i just say hi that's a weird thing too i
don't know whether i should like uh
shake hands give him really because i
don't know what people are comfortable
with right yeah i don't know and then
yeah exactly and then when they're
coming for a hug am i comfortable i
don't know and then i look very awkward
yeah that's the worst thing i haven't
figured out what what that thing is
because i'm a very huggy
i know yeah you are you know and you're
also kind of uncomfortable with the hug
too
depending on the people i'm
uncomfortable when people don't ask and
i don't know you
like we need to have some type of
rapport yeah right and normally too like
let's say it's just like a random fan if
they want to run up and hug me i'm okay
as long as you're not like sexually
harassing me right not that somebody
would but i've had like certain cases
where people thought it was a funny joke
they would grab my ass oh yeah like i
don't i don't [ __ ] with that [ __ ] like
don't do that folks you know like just
be i'm not your object but
you know during this like whole pandemic
thing like yeah there was a couple of
times where people just came up all up
in my business i had no message they
just got so excited yeah which is cool
but it's like yo man you know we had a
time where we have to be a little bit of
that i don't know if you're vaccinated i
don't know if you went to a party and
you have
a fever maybe that's why you caught a
cold awesome you know i actually caught
a cold and i thought i had covered and i
got checked and i didn't have cold but
thank god i just had a common cold oh
but that's like going back to my fitness
i have to say
uh there is this hiking trail that i
went and thank god david didn't go
because
it was
so frightening she was giving me so much
[ __ ] too yeah
okay that's the one thing i mean it's
not that something you could fix but
it's one thing it's like i wish i could
do things like fun adventurous stuff
with you but we do anything but heights
anyway yeah so this place is called coco
head hike and usually or it's a trail
that usually people go on this like
massive
massive
steps and i am still mind blown that
people like to do this well we didn't go
that way we went the back way the head
is like a head trail so coco head if
people don't know there's they also call
it like a stairway to heaven right is
that what it's called
when you see the stairs right so years
ago they banned it but people people
still go on that and when you go to coco
head um
it's stairway to heaven the stairs right
yeah but it doesn't feel like heaven
no it's very very hard right i actually
tried doing that years ago and i almost
went to the top except for at a certain
point the stairs aren't steps anymore
and you're just climbing climbing and i
have a it's a crazy fear of heights like
everybody knows yeah so he didn't go
thank god and i went and it was like the
most fun event i probably had for the
past few years like there was not only
like hiking but they were climbing and
there was just beautiful view um every
time you climb up and it got kind of
scary because you were on this like
really narrow uh roadway or way and you
just fall and die you could yeah so i
literally had to keep telling myself
don't look down don't look down focus on
where you're going like i had to
meditate basically but what i wanted to
bring up is that after that hike which
was way at the top we had to come down
to this forever stairs that what uh
david was talking about and i think it
took legit like an hour to get down and
i was trying to go down really fast and
i was actually
kind of worried whether or not my knee
and my ankle were gonna be fine because
i sprained
um
one of my knees and one of my ankles and
i've been working really hard with my
personal trainer her name is lane from
vitacores and throughout this pandemic
we've been working really hard on it
i've been resting a lot and doing
personal training a lot to get in
physical training or physical therapy to
get them stronger so
through this experience of hiking i've
realized that how much stronger my legs
got because after the end of the trip
my legs were so fine i didn't feel any
pain any soreness i knew weakness
and so i was really happy so i messaged
her i was like dude i think this is
working because i was able to do this
and i'm not dying and i didn't spring my
ankle because usually the case is that
when i'm that exhausted i would sprint
something
but i didn't and so i was really happy i
felt yeah and then she was trying to
peer pressure me and declining this
knowing that i'm so scared of heights i
didn't know it was going to be that
intense but i told you though and the
reason here's the thing too
me not going on that hike is also not
based on just my fears i'm not trying to
ruin everybody else's good time i know
if you came you would have been so
mad at me
i'm not just mad you had to be mad at
everybody
but the thing is it's like i need
somebody like joe to baby me through
that whole thing but joe is also with
his girlfriend yeah joe was helping out
hannah hannah was really good actually
he can't take care of me right so it's
like and then also it would probably be
sean that's going to help me out as well
so i can't i'm not there to ruin
everybody else's good time i know my
abilities i know i could do it you know
why it is because every time you go go
to places without me you always do some
kind of hike some kind of like adventure
stuff with them but then when it's with
me only one time it only happened one
time and i was duped it was by darien
that was one time darian is a monkey yes
he's a little monkey billy goat like i
should you not no hands climbing up
things with justice he's a billy goat he
said he wasn't running
yeah he was like on the edge of a corner
where you could literally just drop and
fall he was just hopping around yeah
that's him that oh i'm sweating yeah so
the last time like i went on a hike and
we talked about on the way why would you
trust darion out of all the people well
the thing is is like joe thought that
the trail from what he remembered wasn't
that bad so he goes okay it's not gonna
be that bad but when he said trail like
when we talk about trails in los angeles
we're thinking that you could wear like
adidas ultra boost and you'll be fine
this [ __ ] was not a trail it was actual
climbing is that coco head no no this
was in la so there's a trail that's
already kind of hard where you have to
climb which i thought was done but there
was another thing where you actually
have to start climbing using your hands
and kind of push yourself in between
rocks to go above on a mountain side it
was i actually climbed climb the
mountains oh i want to go there you
could probably do it dude the climbing
pole was so funny but it was so i i
thought i was gonna die throughout the
whole thing afterwards i had a fever
for two days because the adrenaline
dumped like my immune system was shut
out either yeah
i don't remember this yeah i had a fever
for two days i remember i i my freaking
i had a huge cold sore after here or
he was at the house yeah and i hadn't
had a cold sore in years right so i got
messed up my whole immune system was
shot
well that's a bummer i don't like it no
i am so glad he didn't go
yeah so i did that for you
what have you done for me
what did i do the past two days what did
i do in hawaii a lot of things yes a lot
of things guys well anyways this wraps
up this episode of the genius brain
podcast you can catch marielle at mariel
underscore underscore song hope you guys
enjoyed this i'm so curious too what
would you guys change from your
significant other and be honest you
could be honest just make sure that they
don't really so you don't get in trouble
just make sure you have a backup of like
how you're going to cope with their
reaction
yes
we'll see you all next time every
thursday and sundays genius brain
podcast i love you sons and [ __ ]
peace